What do these two movies have in common? More
than you might think production-wise at least.
The scene where the creature swims below the
unsuspecting Kay is not only beautiful and
iconic- it helped craft another famous water-based
horror scene. Steven Spielberg borrowed elements
from the scene for JAWS' opening moments. Some
scenes are even shot for shot. Each woman dives
into the water and there's a long shot of them
swimming happily until the perspective shifts to
focus on the female swimmer from the monster's
point of view. Sure we get to see Gill-Man
in The Creature from the Black Lagoon, and not
Spielberg's shark. But both films have a similar
mashup of haunting beauty and abject terror.
All the better to emphasize the fear of what
lurks below the water. Oh and another fun fact:
the cry the shark lets out at the end after it's
blown up? Yeah that's a modified version
of Gill-Man's roar!
"Smile you son of a-"